I want to take just a moment up top and
acknowledge the reality that's staring
us in the face today we all woke up
because some absolutely devastating news
this morning what happened last night in
Las Vegas is so terrible and numbing I
don't even need to relate the news
obviously we've seen the images and
they're everywhere and plenty of people
more qualified than I reporting the
tragic facts and asking how this could
happen so I can't speak so intelligently
about that but there is something I can
say and that's that I've been doing this
job for more than 24 years and when I
began in 1993 occasions like this were
extremely rare for me or any TV comedy
hosts back then to come out and need to
address a mass shooting spree was
practically unheard of but over the last
decade things have changed now today
when I came into work my head writer was
standing in my office with a sheaf of
papers and he said here are the remarks
you made after the Sandy Hook shootings
and the pulse nightclub attacks in
Orlando you might want to look at them
to see what you might want to say
tonight and that that struck me how
could there be a file of mass shooting
remarks for a late-night host when did
that become normal when did this become
a ritual and what does it say about us
that it has now I am NOT the most
political of our comics I never have
been but I will repeat what I said not
long ago after Orlando I don't think it
should be so easy for one demented
person to kill so many people
so quickly the sounds of those automatic
weapons last night are grotesquely out
of place in a civilized society it makes
no sense to me as a reasonable human
being and a father and what's more we're
all tired of hearing reporters let alone
comics discuss mass carnage in the most
affluent and influential country in the
history of the world something needs to
change
it really does as for tonight I just
want to express that my staff and I are
truly heartbroken for the families of
all the victims in Las Vegas we
encourage you to help in any way
possible that makes sense to you in the
meantime we have some terrific people
here tonight we really do we're gonna
get back to our show after this break
and try and entertain you and move
forward sorry I have to come out and set
this tone and I thank you very much for
listening thank you